- THE MOOD IS INFECTIOUS
AND EXCITING TODAY
AS PEOPLE FROM
ALL WALKS OF LIFE
CELEBRATE BECOMING
THE SEVENTH STATE
TO LEGALIZE GAY MARRIAGE.
WE'RE HERE TALKING
TO EXCITED COUPLES ABOUT
HOW THEY FEEL
ON THIS HISTORIC DAY.
OH, HI.
- HI, HI.
UH, YEAH, IT'S
A VERY HISTORIC DAY
FOR CIVIL RIGHTS.
- WHOO!
- AND FOR GAY AMERICANS.
AND AMERICANS
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY--
- WHOO! WE'RE GONNA
GET MARRIED! YEAH!
- WELL, YOU KNOW, WAIT--
- [screams]
- WE SAID THAT
IT WOULD BE A CONVERSATION,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T KNOW
THIS WAS GONNA PASS
SO DARN FAST.
- OH, MY GOD!
- SO ARE YOU GUYS A COUPLE?
- [laughs]
ARE WE A COUPLE?
COME ON, GIRL,
LET'S GET SERIOUS.
- NO, IT'S JUST SO FAST.
- MY NAME IS LASHAWN.
AND THIS IS RIGHT HERE
IS MY "SAMWICH."
- IT'S, UH, SAMUEL, YEAH.
- [laughs]
AND WE'RE GONNA
GET MARRIED! YEAH!
- THAT'S SO GREAT.
HOW LONG HAVE YOU GUYS
BEEN TOGETHER?
- WELL, WE'VE BEEN--
- THREE YEARS.
IT'S BEEN FOREVER,
WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOREVER!
- IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO KNOW THE PERSON--
- WHO IS THE BRIDE?
I AM THE BRIDE.
DO-DO-DO-DO-DO-DO-DO!
[laughs]
- OH, WELL TELL US
ALL ABOUT YOUR PLANS.
- YOU KNOW, WE NEVER THOUGHT
IT WAS IMPORTANT TO HAVE
A PIECE OF PAPER
SO THERE'S NOT ANY PLANS--
- OH, YEAH!
PIECE OF PAPER!
WE'RE GONNA GET
THAT PIECE OF PAPER, SAMMY!
- YEAH, YEAH.
- THAT PIECE OF PAPER!
- WHERE DO YOU THINK
YOU GUYS WILL GET MARRIED?
- WELL YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT
OF HIDDEN COSTS IN A WEDDING--
- OH, EVERYWHERE!
WE'RE GONNA
GET MARRIED OVER HERE
AND OVER THERE
AND IN THE SKY AND ON A CLOUD.
- OH, WOW, IT SOUNDS LIKE
IT'S GONNA BE A BIG WEDDING.
- WELL, YOU KNOW IT'S JUST
A CONVERSATION THAT WE HAVE--
- GIRL, WE'RE GONNA RENT
THE MOON AND FILL IT WITH ROSES!
[screams]
- WE REALLY NEED TO TALK
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT WE THINK
IT'S FAIR TO EVEN GET MARRIED
WHEN IT'S STILL ILLEGAL
IN SO MANY
OTHER STATES--
- OH, MY GOD!
YOU SEE? LOOK AT HIM!
THAT'S MY MAN
WITH HIS BIG HEART.
I'M SORRY, MY HUSBAND.
YOU MY HUSBAND NOW.
- WELL, WE JUST--
- YOU MY HUSBAND NOW, BITCH.
- OKAY, WE JUST DON'T WANNA
RUSH INTO ANYTHING,
BECAUSE STUFF
GETS OVERTURNED.
REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED
IN CALIFORNIA.
- BABY I'M GONNA
GET A 14-KARAT RING
THE SIZE
OF 14 MOTHER[bleep] CARROTS.
THAT'S WHAT'S UP, DOC!
[smacking lips]
- WELL, YOU TWO
CERTAINLY SEEM EXCITED.
- YEAH, DO WE SEEM EXCITED?
- OH, YEAH, YEAH.
- OH, OKAY.
- CONGRATULATIONS.
I HOPE YOU GUYS
HAVE A WONDERFUL LIFE TOGETHER.
- WE JUST--WE REALLY JUST
DIDN'T THINK IT WAS GONNA PASS.
- WE'RE GONNA HAVE A HOUSE
THAT'S SHAPED LIKE A UNICORN
AND WE'RE GONNA
HAVE FIVE LITTLE GIRLS.
THEIR NAMES ARE GONNA BE
ETNIE, CAROUSEL, SEQUIN,
ABERCROMBIE, AND PHANTOM.
AND WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A LITTLE DOG NAMED RUFFALO.
AND THE DOG GONNA
HAVE A CAT NAMED MYRIAD.
[intense newscast music]